foreign
people welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for Hot D that's great it's
time we're doing it we done did it um
I'm not entirely sure why we're doing
this from home today what happened Ryan
what's going on oh boring stuff that no
one did uh no
I was down to drive in the office today
and I might just do it later for fun
because it's a lovely place and then
also we don't know where lawn is we hope
he's okay
it was look he was slacking like he was
on slack like five minutes ago so we
don't know what happened
um hopefully he's taking the dog for a
walk and I do mean that as a euphemism
for pooping
um but he should be he should be here at
some point in the hour because we we
love and value his opinions
um Danielle is here uh as always
um my erstwhile uh uh my queen my queen
who will lead us to be I should have
worn a blonde you should have worn a you
could probably get a mop and like do a
half decent job of a Valerian yo all
right well Halloween was yesterday
uh but if you haven't been watching the
show before Australia a couple of days
we're gonna watch the Australia together
we'll talk about it we'll show you some
deleted scenes of which I do believe we
have a few this time
um long show and uh we'll do some q a so
keep your questions coming in the chat
then we'll tease you with next week's
honest trailer uh which should be fun so
um the D is hot is it not uh I really
enjoyed this show uh all the way through
I wish I didn't I wish I could just be
like I'm done with this this with this
world I can delete every piece of proper
noun that I learned from from the house
of uh fire and from Fire and Blood and
all the appendices of all the Game of
Thrones the Wiki of Ice and Fire just
done just to delete it for my brain but
no I'm back as Ryan said we've been
fully westerospilled we're back in there
um when he's dead may never die but rise
again and yeah I just I just love it I I
slid right back in I'm so happy that uh
that this show is off is good
and it has an ending that we know
they're building towards um that George
R Martin or well so I haven't because
you're like an avid now I've read all of
the Game of Thrones books except for the
one that will never come out
um but so I know that you actually read
this series like you are an avid players
games of thrones dude this is uh well
and but even still like I have just a
you know a Swiss cheese brain for
um for uh names and places content in it
I know too much content it's leaking out
of every hole so yeah the um the thing
take that dog for a walk yeah it's a
it's this is based on a West a westerosi
history book
um I think it's called Fire and Blood
but like the chapters like the dance of
Dragons It's like this Targaryen Civil
War it's covered by
um even within the there's a book within
the book because this period of history
is covered by a maester and a court
jester and they're both giving like
their sides of the story of what
happened through this era wait no so
we're like literally sitting through
someone's incestry like history class
yeah 100 100
um that's that's what this show is based
on is like a a section of a fake
westerosi textbook that a maester wrote
and then there's this I guess I think
he's a court gesture I don't know what a
term is in in this world uh mushroom is
talking about like oh but maybe she was
sleeping with him oh so there's like two
kind of conflicting cats and the show is
sort of like here's what really happened
uh during during this time period so we
know the broad outlines we know like who
wins so I know you know which side comes
out on top and how and why um there have
been slight changes
um and also they leave it ambiguous
enough like they all think that they
both agree that uh Lenor uh Prince Eric
as we call him honest Trail like he they
say he died but as we learned in the
show they actually like let him go be
gay and happy somewhere else um but that
makes sense that those historians quote
unquote would not know about that so
there's wiggle room to to change some
things for the show
I just like it man it's well acted it
looks good
um and it's uh it's like I like the
world of um
it's fantasy it's obviously it's like
high fantasy because you got dragons and
stuff and Magic but they are really
taking uh feudal politics fake feudal
politics very seriously and I don't know
man it's just a I just have a soft spot
for it I remember the slack like when
the first episode came out and we were
all like begrudgingly like oh I think I
like it yeah
yeah damn it
I think this might be be fun and yeah no
it's
um
because
you know the dragons and everything
obviously awesome love all that high
fantasy stuff it's amazing but you watch
Game of Thrones because you want to
watch like politicking and this is
super politicking although I do wish
that everyone
um
everyone wore like one of those hi my
name is stickers
that would be great oh this is the one
time I wish all of the white-haired
people like I just yeah I want just like
a like I want lower thirds for everyone
but like that was actually very helpful
with um rings of power was the last
Amazon Prime x-ray thing that you could
kind of hover over me like okay
um that all those names are gone but
yeah I do know uh it there I was fine
with the first generation but once they
couple the time Jump with like six new
kids absolutely I don't know my aiming
for my anus man there's there's too many
there's two too many A's
too many A's and it's like I do I
appreciate uh I appreciate that they
just like let us get in a dark-haired
person every once in a while so I could
be like I know you you know we call that
diversity
I'm glad that they brought in their
token dark-haired people their children
brunette their token hires
um so I would know who any of these
people are because it's like it was like
oh man even the Negroes have white hair
well now I'm stuck yeah all three of
these women look alike to me I don't
know what to do with it yeah it's uh
it's tough but I mean fantasy suffers
from that in general but
um when you have such a big cast on a TV
show plus time jumps it was uh it was
not easy but overall we liked it a lot
but plenty of things to nitpick as is or
wants to do so let's watch Tiana's
trailer and stop and start with more
thoughts
the casting was really good on the time
jumps though man yeah
foreign
you stay up to watch as an adult and the
pre-internet porn you stayed up to watch
as a kid comes and pumps
shout out to all my real sex fans
growing up kids don't know kids you
don't know you don't know how good you
got it do ya look there was a point in
which David Duchovny would come out on a
show and be like oh we're gonna talk
about this sexy thing that happened it
would be like X-Files it's like no like
triple X Files like it was y'all don't
understand you could we had to watch
static in the shape of a boob hoping
that it would like briefly resolve into
something that vaguely resembled a woman
you would like close one eye and try to
like squint with the other to like see
if you could see what was happening and
now it's like I won't even I can't even
imagine the idea of having an actual
boob on my full TV like that's for
phones and phones only
everything was like yeah it was like a
magic eye for porn you had to like
unfocus yeah
[Laughter]
kids these days are like oh yeah I
schooned her that was that's first base
you know what I'm saying hey
um but yeah real sex was like it was a
for those who don't know and tax cap
confessions after midnight on HBO there
were these programs like in Cinemax you
know skinamax they would have your your
soft cores and stuff and they were just
horrifying yeah these just repulsive
mini documentaries about like 80 year
olds who like stretch their balls in the
sauna and then like and then but like
you'll see a stray boob somewhere it was
great and we're not look we're not Kink
shaming I'm just saying that when I was
like 11 I didn't need to know about
clown sex and people who like to like
rub against balloons like that was all
all we had
um so there you go a little history
lesson that Ryan says it's not TV it's
porn in the chat ain't that the truth uh
it was and yet it worked for it it's my
point
um now it's too easy yeah anyways let's
keep let's keep going willest Rose in
search of an heir to Game of Thrones
because every other trueborn son of
their parent company is dead
House of the Dragon
remember Daenerys
girls named Khaleesi sure do turns out
she and her brother weren't the only
nuts in the Targaryen family tree yeah
pause there are um I know it said 755
but I think I looked it up and there's
like 700 girls named Khaleesi and like a
hundred something named Daenerys so
that's uh I'd love to a documentary
following them throughout their lives to
see what becomes true look I just as a
Danielle uh who almost but never quite
became a Danny because I didn't do
Sports I did theater
um because when I tried to cheerlead
they immediately were like oh your
name's Danny now and I was like I think
I want to do theater
um
it's they're all going to be Danny's is
what's gonna happen they're all gonna be
bad that's a good point and the but the
Khaleesi's though
I don't know what to do Cali Cali yeah
you just probably
right
oh well I mean look an influencer named
their child Malibu Barbie so like
anything can happen no
incredible well yeah you just gotta not
name your kid after uh pop culture
because we well no but that's the thing
it never ends so you're always you know
one bad reboot away from making them
into a joke again so yeah uh sorry
Megatron Wolverine my unborn son
so I'll have to think of a new name I'm
just gonna name my first kid after like
the noise that Transformers make like
that's a Elon Musk kid right yeah
yeah uh all right keep going you revisit
a civil war between rival factions of
goth albino sociopaths that only goes
down because so many talks are named
aegon aegon the prince that was promised
you are the one awesome
don't like that nope not not a fan
um that was a that was one thing that
was an invention of the show completely
is like the importance of the prophecy
that ties into Game of Thrones the
original
200 years don't remind me don't remind
me there's plenty of it just also seemed
like doubly like over determined because
there was plenty of reasons without that
for them to go to war against each other
like her whole Council had been like
yeah we've been playing this like we
were just waiting to tell you like we're
going to war we're putting them putting
a minion on the throne yeah we're
putting the man on there problems ain't
for girls ain't for sitting on girl yeah
too hard
um so they didn't need that uh
especially when it just reminds you of
how Game of Thrones ended in my opinion
maybe they'll do another twist with the
prophecy like a Hodor thing to be like
oh it actually does make sense but for
now no not like no yeah I think it was
like just a cutesy thing to be like hey
remember that thing you liked it's like
no you guys don't remember no no no no
no not that part not that part oh well
uh yeah all right keep going choose a
side to root four even though the only
thing these extremely out of touch rich
people have in common with their
extremely poor subjects is in reading
hey Raymond come out and look this one's
got a funny eye like you
a whole new challenge the character is
trying to satisfy their raging throwners
like Prince demon a fully armed and
operational Joffrey if you're accusing
me of some depravity you'll need to be
more specific watch Matt Smith continue
the hot streak he's been on since Mormon
time as this homicidal narcissist with a
limb noodle
we can only get it up for his family
anyway are you okay internet viserys a
stellar performance by Patty Constantine
as a king succumbing Parts falling off
disease
uh Bravo I I love this character I think
he was I think I said this on another
video but I think he's a new
he does break with the tropes of fantasy
in the sense that I feel like kings are
either uh good or bad uh they they kind
of fall into oh the Wicked the wicked
ruler or the saintly ruler was promised
and he's just like ah God I don't want
to deal with this like yeah fine fine
I'll do it he's mostly like that
everybody like me
he is an influencer it's just like just
like me just everyone like me please
like each other yeah can you just like I
just want to go play with my toys
a freaking hunt I'm in so much pain yeah
yeah like everything hurts all of the
time my daughter's a brat my brother
wants to Bunk like wants to like bed my
daughter my face is falling off my face
is falling off my daughter's best friend
is trying to bang me and I'm probably
gonna let her so can I just like have
one day where none of you bother me he's
like Tim the toolman Taylor he just
wants like one day where no one bugs it
yeah it's great so uh Bravo to uh and
Patty like the the role of a lifetime
there um he really I've always thought
that he should like have more meaty
stuff uh so I'm really glad that he got
this and I'm hoping that more people
will cast him in things where he gets to
do this and not just be easily funny man
there you go
um so yeah really good casting all
around as he said
um okay keep going no longer a handsome
one who just wants to hang out in his
room and play with his artisanal
Minifigs all day he'll declare his
daughter raniero as Heir a girl who
looks like she just found out she isn't
getting a pony who gets hardened sharpen
and aged about 20 years when her bestie
becomes her stepmom rainhera must fight
for women's rights over the women's
wrongs of Alison Hightower she said
he is
your blood
his words to me and I was the only one
to hear it
[Music]
thank you
then they're supporting players like
Otto Hightower the hand of the king and
the king of the passive aggressive
remark perhaps there's some better use
for the princess's Town
Kristen Cole a hard enough I mean come
on look at that face which one uh
Kristen
well Kristen Cole I am he's going to
without resorting to spoilers uh if you
don't like him now just wait
um although they did he did have like
quite the arc because when they
introduce him as a uh as like a foil to
Damon and like he beats his ass in the
tournament you're like all right all
right yes and he's dornish nice
um but then they uh man he really has a
really can't get over that one that one
hot night he had her in here
foreign
she was not going to run off with you
um it's just not gonna happen bro
um but yeah
uh yeah you'll see you'll see some good
stuff with him coming and then Auto High
Tire like
I liked him there was a lot of
um
Auto high tower like where does he stand
in like the all-time Game of Thrones
schemer schemer rankings oh he's like
he is one of those instigators where
it's like
you really have to someone would have to
come up to you and be like you know what
he's doing right because he's so slick
he's like I think one of the slickest I
think the Slicker yeah he's slicker than
you than you give him credit for because
he's not
so obviously scheming even though he's
he's oh we gotta we got I think there's
a lot you have a road lawn
um just a in a nice third act twist
just me least expect it he's logging in
but we'll keep talking about Otto for
now
um he's uh oh oh do we have a third hey
we have a rogue one hey everybody sorry
about that
what's up man hey
um we were just talking about Auto
Hightower and where he ranks in the in
the uh schemers uh the all-time scheme
right my theory like I think that he's
very like because he's not like uh uh
you know obviously not the same series
but he's not like Worm tongue where it's
very obvious he's like I am the evilest
person in the world and he's not like
little finger where it's kind of very
obvious like I am the evilest person in
the world he's more of a like look as
your friend as your best friend I just
have to tell you and as your father it'd
be really nice to go Comfort the King
right now he could use somebody to
exactly gross sorry there's a cat uh
hugging me
um my cat really likes Auto Hightower
yeah
it's one of those things where it I
think little finger sort of spells this
out at one point A Game of Thrones that
it's not necessarily like
it's a plan and I have this plan that
it's like step by step and here's
everything that's going to happen over
the next several years like a prophecy
it's like just keep lining up your
pieces in the right or you know it's
like it's like open enough that you can
still strategize in an individual way
but but flexible enough that you're
still setting things up for multiple
scenarios eventually working out for you
and it's like I think it's it's that
it's that kind of thinking that this
that I think the most effective yeah
just putting the people that he trusts
in places where he could like figure out
anything as long as he has his people in
place and it's sort of like posing
that's happening with one of those right
and sort of opposing that with like a
guy like Corliss Valerian who's sort of
like right out in front like no it's me
it should be me put me in you know like
yeah what I think um I think subtly
boosts some of the rankings for me is
the longevity and um like he's somebody
who like he's just he's got a great
career you know he's spanning multiple
dynasties and then and then we've
weaving his own into the royal family
um by getting his daughter up there is
he Steinbrenner
yeah he's like I was gonna go LeBron
like he's like he's like consistently
because like Littlefinger like I mean
what a rise like started from the bottom
now he's here like he really climbed
from nothing to uh to something but um
you know he's born Otto is like at the
high Towers or a noble like prestigious
family that he probably would have um
but he he held on to that and held held
his place against uh Challengers for all
that time uh which is which is something
like that that long career Arc not
making too many waves just kind of
waiting and biting your time until it's
right and then that's how you that's how
you sit on the throne man you can't uh
you can't be making these big huge
swings like look people are posted in
the comments like Tywin Tywin Lannister
like you did too much man you got your
kid on the throne but like at what cost
it lasted like a few maybe a couple
years and then he choked at his wedding
like you gotta you gotta mellow it out
so you can
literally just described Joe Biden yeah
you got to be a Centrist uh example
pleaser and then um you know no one will
overthrow you I don't know well it's
interesting too that that how much
Dragon sort of add to it complicate the
mix because like it's it's like a third
it used to be you know that you got
armies and like there that that's
important and then funding you know like
then those were the two things it's like
maybe ships you know like well they've
got the ships but they've got all the
money but we've got the largest army and
like now it's just like well there's a
whole other piece on the board in this
era and it's like yeah yeah right
they've got like five dragons so that
there there goes that whole Advantage
yeah yeah uh well interesting will be
interesting to watch uh again no
spoilers but you know we you can look up
how this all ends if you want uh let's
keep going but don't yeah it's still the
most fragile white night in the land
spoiled oh hey pretty
the valyrians an ancient family who
bring much needed diversity to people
and ridiculous white wigs and lurking
ever lurking is Laris strong who's like
Littlefinger if he were more into little
piggies instead
[Music]
free
she's paying him off yeah this is a I
think um Laris was a fantastic addition
to the show because things were a little
quid pro toe I hate you so much Ryan
that's so good things are pretty
straightforward uh at the beginning of
the show like the first four episodes
like it was pretty contained to just
these main Targaryen and high towers and
like there weren't enough wild cards
there weren't enough like weird little
people in the background
um and then bam they hit us with Laris
and I am all the way back in uh I
thought he was just he's the spice that
makes uh that makes the Game of Thrones
do work I think
um
yeah uh and where and if you put him
in the ranking of like Laris
Littlefinger
Otto high tower where do you where do
you rank those three oh he's below all
of them like his uh piccadillos are
gonna be what gets him like caught up in
my theory
um is that like because with the other
two I feel like they are very
single-minded but with him it's just
like bruh you got too many depravities
like there's no way like that yeah
that's what's going to get you caught up
well it's it's an interesting thing too
I mean I think there there's always
where there's one you know we're always
kind of assuming everybody's chasing the
same thing like the The Throne or or at
least like the throne for their house
and with him he just wants feet yeah
yeah all right I think like he's an
interesting character because even
Littlefinger was after the the same like
the pursuit of power the pursuit of well
and um
yeah right you want yeah
right but he wanted to like he still
wanted to like rise up the ladder and I
feel like hilarious it doesn't feel to
me like he's tremendously into like I
gotta have a better showing at court or
I have to have a fancier title or I need
to do more he doesn't care about his
house at all I think it's really more
like uh what can I get out you know like
hey these guys kind of playing the
angles because he's a weird creep and
like oh what what can I how can I
service being a weird creep the most and
like I feel like that's kind of a new
element you know like somebody who's not
in it for any kind of long-term status
gain but it's just like playing it to
see what they can get for themselves
yeah and he's also a weird hot creep
which is like you could just not creep
wow huh I wouldn't have thought I don't
think they're going up I'm sorry no
they're not going down
I think he could get feet for free
without having to kill people
um I think he could just get all right
hey
you heard it here first uh folks I've
been on Twitter
I see what you all sacrifice yourself
for women stand up
I think uh they're they're definitely
also playing with that same it's like
it's it was a it was a benigned time for
people with obvious
physical problems or or disabilities and
I think with the same thing they were
playing with you know with like uh with
like just characterian thank you uh you
know like that that idea that it would
it was as bad as it is today and as much
stigma as you will face in today's dumb
society that dumb Society was like far
worse and it really would put you in
this place where you would feel like a
true Outcast he's still hot he's just a
creep
the fact that he you know he's got that
obvious sort of disability and I think
there's talk of like he's not able to
like do the normal things the Lord and
his situation would do and he's not seen
as like a marriageable prospect and all
these other things they sort of kept him
from feeling even as a second or a third
son of an aristocratic house that he
would feel like he has a place yeah
um
not to throw John uh Bailey under the
bus but I did uh I I got that line in a
pickup of you know I said uh say we we
like the little piggies thing I'm not
sure he's ever heard that we we all the
way all the way I think she went he went
Deliverance instead of um
it still works it's funny that's a way
to squeal like a pig yeah yeah all right
keep going
if you thought MTV's lineup was full of
hard to watch pregnancies strap in for a
show that's more comfortable with dead
mobs and stillbirths than a red State
Legislature where the showrunner had to
explicitly promise to tone it down this
time and though their female characters
go through hell easy access to plan T it
will rid you of any unwanted
consequences it's best to be certain
my guess is that's based on raspberry
leaf tea which uh back in the day uh was
both used as a way to um and who knows
if it was real this is like one of those
uh don't trust Tick Tock but I remember
this being a thing when I was a kid
um people would be like oh well if you
can't get uh Plan B you can just like
drink raspberry leaf tea and it will
make you have a
or if you are like nine months pregnant
and you're ready for that baby to come
out you drink raspberry leaf tea and
that makes that baby come down so that
is that is based in something yeah
there's a lot of um
Homespun stuff about uh let's call it
homeopathic stuff about
um those things and that I wonder uh
there's a place in Los Angeles when my
wife was pregnant that apparently has a
special salad that will like induce
labor
wow all right and I'm going home oh wait
I'm already home sorry
um and yeah apparently there's like
castor oil in the dressing or like
something that like uh that like
kick-starts things if you're and
apparently this place is full of very
pregnant women trying to get the baby
out eating this salad believe yourself
yeah there's a lot of homeopathic stuff
but yes so that is at least something
where it's like I don't know if I
believe any of these things but I do
know that some people on the planet I
live on do believe that this thing's a
thing there you go
um doesn't taste like raspberries though
which is unfortunate
um yeah well no because raspberry leaf
yeah it's not the actual raspberry
keep going before winter came all over
it but don't worry the baratheons are
still dumb where's the bloody may stop
the Starks are still loyal that has
never lived a stark who forgotten oath
Lannister's smog targaryen's cuckoo the
episode's directed by Miguel sapotnik
impossible to see and now more than dude
how did you not
learned the last time I had to like turn
uh uh I couldn't even watch it on my
regular TV because it was like I can't
turn the brightness up enough I could
freaking see it I had to like cast it on
um
uh I had to cast it I casted it on my
big TV and that didn't work I cast it on
my laptop and that didn't work I
literally had to put it on my phone
which is wild because it was the only
one I could turn the brightness up
enough where I could actually see what
was happening here's here's the problem
is that they shoot this and edit it on
the best equipment possible like 800k uh
cameras and and editing consoles and
monitors and stuff like that you are
seeing more detail when they make the
show than when they stream it on like
over your like sub DSL web connection or
whatever it gets compressed and you and
we all have shittier TVs than they do so
just have somebody on set with a photo
watching it also on the top on the phone
yes and being like I can't see it okay
sorry I can't see the dragon I don't
know what that is yeah I don't know what
that is it's easier for us to turn the
brightness down than it is for us to
turn it bright enough to see is my guess
so come on Miguel we we've been over
this in the the Battle of Winterfell
um I mean it really it does also feel
like now that we are decidedly in the
streaming era we know everybody is
watching all of this stuff on
televisions or or on laptops or
computers or whatever
uh it like maybe just the new standard
would be look it your your show is your
content is going to be seen in like a
medium light room it's not going to be
seen in a movie theater because all of
these standards were set when the
presumption was darkened theater yep and
that's the best way to project something
and see it show up and be bright and
have contrast and it doesn't pop like
ever on a screen the way it does on a
movie screen so we should stop watching
this at the DMV like there are
fluorescent bulbs above right and I mean
I think yeah like a living room with
like a light on in the Next Room is like
that's how most people are gonna watch
it so you should plan on that being the
atmosphere yep
all right now you know uh keep going the
dragons enormous ex machina is that keep
surprising people despite being as big
and loud as a 747.
there we go that's the writing quality
we got used to starting to feel like old
times again Danny kind of forgot about
the iron Fleet
Matt Damon you're an uncle lover yes
it's true nobody loves uncles quite Like
You It's Not Easy Being Green the queen
who never guessed The Dread pirate
cordless King Louis of CK you'll pay for
this Potter Hollywood first Chris Prince
Eric that's what I do I lurk and I tow
things the lion creeps tonight
luceris looking like a snack
meeting balls I wonder what those are
for
oh a human spoiler alert
and calling someone a without really
saying it soon I'll let you make it when
it looks like you there's a New Jersey
oh strong does your brother mention if
this one also Bears a market but
entirely coincidental resemblance to the
command of the city watch here's son
what grounds could there be indeed Lord
beesbury what but indeed come on you
know you want to say it our children
oh
he said it you were in so much trouble
I love that that is a total like Friday
oh yeah I love that like that's the
problem but not the best
it's like they're not black enough
they're not black
sorry that's it that's all I had to say
that's right yeah it was it was an
interesting decision for a show that was
obsessed with like Purity and like uh
lineage and stuff like that that it did
revolve around the kids not being black
enough I I was saying I would think
about it this way imagine if the
valerians all look in like they did in
the books exactly like the targaryens
imagine trying to keep all of those
characters separate I think that was a
very I think there was a very compelling
show specific reason to make the
valerians black it it does help visually
we immediately know which are the
Valerian kids or which of the Targaryen
kids so in addition to it being a
wonderful thing to open up and diversify
the cast just on principle I actually
feel like there was a good storytelling
and aesthetic reason to do it in this
one and then even more helpful to call
that side of the Civil War the blacks
oh right okay got it they cut that they
got that one from Curb Your Enthusiasm
that was a Larry game
[Laughter]
hello for regally blonde blonde that was
um that's a that's an all-timer thank
you thank you yeah uh all right let's
let's finish it up towards the end of
the world of men just to begin with a
terrible winter and if the world of
menace to survive a Targaryen must be
seated on the iron throne and actually
all you really need is a stark with two
Working Hands
yeah brand could have already been paid
for that that would have been fine uh
uh
anyways ain't going to stream said there
had to be a man on the throne who had a
very good story
we got to give you a very good story
I don't want someone on the throne with
a very good story I want someone who is
good at loss and stuff that was they
should have just called George and been
like George we're a little stuck why is
Brett why do they make bread cake it's a
weird yeah you can it almost feels like
they didn't want spoilers that's like no
you kind of yeah
well I just had a little outline and on
it was like brand becomes king and they
were like oh fascinating I wonder why
Brad becomes cake but did it because I
know four days later like they shot the
um they shot multiple endings uh or had
multiple scripts at least for who they
appoint as king at the end and I wonder
a like even if George R Martin thought
that bran would be king when they
talked about the outline you know uh
seven years ago
I'm sure he's pivoted by now I'm sure
George Martin is like that didn't go
well oh okay well that was that was a
weird call but all right well you know
we'll find out when the new book
didn't you hear he's 75 to 76 and a half
percent done uh yeah it's like an anime
villain where it's like he's only using
80. he's charging up
oh no
oh man all right uh we still got um
outtakes and questions to get to but
I'll pause right now to say thank you
for watching please like And subscribe
and hit the little notification Bell if
you haven't yet uh we have a fun episode
of by the Numbers uh that came up this
week as well comparing all the nudity
and violence and lives and incest and
all the things you pay to watch uh for
free
um uh in a uh convenient Forum right to
your this side of your screen you can
click the the by the Numbers video and
check that out after this one uh between
Game of Thrones and House of dragon we
also have
um an Andor stream tomorrow
um
uh Ryan is pleading with me in the
script to react to the news
we need to do an sju like uh reaction
yeah some people were asking for some
Witcher thoughts since it's tangentially
in the world or you know in the sphere
of big budget fantasy streaming shows
yeah
um okay well we'll we'll do that at the
during the Q a time um we'll we'll stay
tuned for that
um
and uh yeah whatever you know what I
want to do because I'm just going to be
doing it anyways is this Friday I want
to watch The Weird Al movie so if
anybody wants to watch The Weird Al
movie yeah
um
how do we get the Roku Channel yeah you
gotta stream the Roku chick yeah
you can watch that on the web you can
just like log in I think it's free I
think we can get fandom to buy Roku if
we ask them enough
I mean
but if you guys want to watch along I'm
I think we should just do that together
because I want to do that anyways this
Friday so um we'll we'll put that
together and we can all watch um podcast
that I have to do it like nine but I'll
be done by 10 30 and then let's watch
Weird Al let's just watch Weird Al uh at
some point on Friday so stay tuned for
that
um all right uh outtakes we got some
outtakes Let's Roll
when Thrones ended three years ago they
declared he with the best story would be
king you know Bran who has a better
story than bran the broken everyone else
HBO is banking on your love for the
early seasons and firing the smooth
brains who tried to bring you
Confederate while taking orders from the
Mind who came up with a red wedding
never bet against Double R Martin he'll
do anything to not finish Winds of
Winter anything
starring
King of Pain Dr ew niece and desist
Target the princess who got promised the
bossed daughter the girl and the high
tower
drift key wait why wasn't that a man
naked and afraid
you are not the father foot stalker
Quinton on the Delo
family feudal
the air up there
the Queens gambits
there are in fact various Queens who
making gambits various gambits
indeed are an accurate title yeah uh all
right let's move on to the Q a uh gym 1s
thoughts on the time jumps the only
issue I had where they reduce the impact
of Harwin strong and Lena's deaths it
felt like we did not get a lot of time
with them uh thoughts on the time jumps
anyone
um I I it was one of those things where
I felt like do you not know if you're
going to get a second season because I
feel like if this was years ago back
when the streaming was were like full-on
in their War it would have been that
they wouldn't we would not have had a
bunch of time jumps they would have
filled that time out so that they could
make sure that they would get this to
whatever and then the
um combination of kind of
the eventual bubble bursting of
streaming stuff along with the ending of
uh the original Game of Thrones being
kind of like unenthusiastically uh uh
received made it where they were like
let's just jump in time and just get to
where we're going like let's just get to
the fireworks Factory no I don't think
that's true I think it's the textbook
that this one's not written like a novel
it's written like a history of the whole
Dynasty I don't really know how you do
this show in a conventional narrative
way because you you want to start you
could have done it without the recasting
I feel like the time jumps there was no
real way to avoid it you could have just
cast actresses and asked them to play a
few years younger in the beginning and
then a few years older well we were
talking about that before you got here
and I I have to say like the the
recasting is very well done yeah like
those were two of the only characters
where I was like oh I still know who you
are I I think it was well done I'm just
saying you could have you could have
softened that blow they did that on
purpose to kind of create independent
feeling sections so we get the like you
know oh this was the long-term impact of
this early stuff that happened but I
feel like uh I don't know how you do it
without like well we got a leap a few
years here because otherwise you want to
open with viserys at the height of his
powers making these fateful decisions
before I guess the the decline yeah
right because then that that would lose
impact if you just jump if we started
and he was already this like falling
apart I'm not saying you're wrong I'm
saying it's what they would have done
two people saying he wanted to go back
even further and actually start like
this show we get a little prologue when
it's them picking viserys over rainies
to be the the next king yeah Martin was
saying he actually wanted to start the
show there there would be a few episodes
then and then you'd jump to viserys and
then you jump to give that renice this
Sarah's relationship more so it's like
you're gonna kind of lose a little
something wherever you go I think people
are right then you do lose some of the
impact of stuff like Harwin strong and
Sir laying or because we haven't gotten
to know them as well but you were just
we're sacrificing them for other
characters you know like they're it's
always a trade-off at some point I think
I'm here here well uh still good I I
would be fine if they started with aegon
the Conqueror or whatever uh which which
leads into our next question from
nachiket make how many people are named
aegon in this show who knows only two in
this show one live one I guess I guess
one but there's
I can think I can think of offhand like
there's got to be at least five aegons
because well a got the fifth is the one
who is he's the father of the Mad King
right he's no well maybe he is he's egg
from Duncan Duncan
yes I believe he's also the father of
the the Mad kid like he's the king
before the Mad King who's the one who
gets deposed he's the fifth so there's
at least five there and then Jon Snow's
true name
aegon Targaryen right there's a lot of
aegons is my point sorry
yeah in this show there's just the guy
who becomes Louie of CK in our in our
video he's aegon the second and he
becomes king and the other aegon was the
Conqueror back in history yeah
um all right so uh liquor saying or asks
a question it brings a power and House
of the Dragon had a foreign
acting effect story wigs Etc or ask
Danielle anything about wigs so Danielle
I mean if it's we could get wig versus
wig which also uh versus was great until
they messed it up with money I'm very
sad I love verses
um I mean if we're just going based on
wigs then
I I gotta go with them rings
I gotta go with them Reigns
um sorry Hot D sucks on wigs it just
does
um and that's okay that's fine but you
know if it's like a versus versus acting
effects story wigs Etc
it's hard to say because I want to say
that like the um
the locations of Dem Rings were so
gorgeous everything looked great most of
it was practical it looked amazing
um but that's also a story about like
moving around being in different places
whereas this is uh uh uh like Game of
Thrones has always been a story about
like things Shady things happening and
shadier smaller rooms a lot of uh yeah a
lot of um red keep and a lot of uh
really drafty looking throne rooms for a
lot of different things every place
looked miserable to just sit in and be
like well I guess I'm the king here but
it serves the story so you can't be like
oh it's terrible because it's like no
that's the story that they're no there
are child fighting pits here I do like
the uh Laris strong is the first one who
seems like he's not really that into the
sigil thing like the strong House has
their own sigil but he's like oh I'm
gonna be this lightning bug guy like uh
I'm gonna go I'm going a different way
with it hey there have you seen a
lightning bug they're pretty cool we've
really never seen like we've never seen
that eat like every even because like
Dave and Targaryen he's kind of the
black sheep of the family but he's still
in the dragons as a thief as a personal
Thief yeah
[Music]
um this was interesting on the end on uh
green star said what do you think of the
different Dragon designs I enjoyed how I
could tell those ones apart and I could
which I thought was very impressive it
usually
um dragons all look alike is that okay
to say they all look like to me oh I see
oh yeah
I've been canceled by a big dragon
um but I thought that they did a great
job
personalities I do like I remember iraqs
and um Valeria was it Valerian see
that's the thing it's like I draw the
line at remembering their names I'm not
gonna remember your pet's name if I'm
struggling to remember your name so I
went people first and I kind of hit my
cap but I did
a really big one that eats the smaller
dragon and the boy who's riding it in
this one like that that's the most
important dragon from season one to
remember I believe yeah so that was
pretty cool I thought they did a really
good job I liked how they're they're
very much drawing this decision because
it would have been a very important
distinction to the targaryens that you
could always tell the huge ancient
dragons that have been around for
forever they're like a different
category than the younger newer smaller
models and like that's thematic because
like they keep the dragons keep getting
sort of smaller and weaker until they
eventually like disappear entirely and
then when by the time Daenerys comes
around she's got the only surviving ones
or the only living ones yeah
um cool stuff man I I'm sad that we have
to wait two years to come back uh but
um yeah if it makes for a better story I
would rather have that please do not
rush me to make one of these yep
um so good for you uh zazlov you gotta
you gotta hit on your hands um you
really you really put in the the work to
make HBO uh to to keep it in the in the
black as they say
um wow okay so yes we gotta you gotta
say good luck Casey boys he's the guy
that runs HBO content this is his baby
uh and he was that like it it he he ends
up looking like Savant like he's got
feige level uh you know Optics on this
because he was the one who was looking
at like 10 Game of Thrones spin-off
projects going
Jane Goldman made that they spent a lot
of money on they were all good to go and
that one set during like Age of Heroes
long night like ancient history uh and
so yeah he made the call like nope not
good enough We're not gonna do that one
let's try this one instead about the
targaryens and the same thing happened
with the Game of Thrones pilot where
they recast and they they completely
redid it uh I think a couple times so
yeah yeah boys with kind of the Magic
Touch you know like that's that's a
that's impressive to pick a winner out
of that crop yeah nicely done
um well we'll be back next week with a
holiday sequel
um it's it's about that time
um I think it's going to be an enjoyable
Nostalgia trip uh to a place that um
we've all been before even on Honest
Trailers so that's your clue
um notable a notable Cameo very notable
film with a famous iconic Camp it's not
afraid to get political we'll put it
that way
um so we'll see you next week uh here on
Australia thanks for watching bye-bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]